In this lesson, you'll become more familiar with ANOVA by going through a full
length example that not only includes calculating the F statistic, but learning
about and calculating a measure of effect size for the differences between
three or more groups. This is similar to Cohen's d for the t tests. To improve
the lives of dairy cows, a researcher examined 3 types of foods, they wanted to
assess cows prefernece for one food over the other all were equally nutritous
and afforadable. Together the farmer and the researcher gave the cows each type
of food there were nine cows bessie frank and slim got food a Bob, Red, and
Pippin got food B. Sam, Merry, and Chip got food C. They were randomly assigned
to each type of food. Over eight hours this is the amount that these cows
consumed in pounds. The data can be visualized with bar graphs. Before we get
started with our analysis, match the independent variable dependent variable,
null an alternative hypothesis, with the column on the right. Not all of these
will be used. Put the appropriate letter next to each.